once we oversimplify and reduce things
then those who disagree with us are
caricatured and demonized into just bad
people yep it's and it's never that
simple almost ever I I think a
Christian's duty is to bring healing to
the world and to be the hands and feet
of Christ and to bring love uh to our to
our neighbor to love our neighbor as
Christ told us and I think do a big part
of that is complicating The Narrative
resisting those easy answers because I
think that's a big part of loving our
neighbor
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast Chief National correspondent for
Yahoo news and author of The phenomenal
new book testimony inside the
Evangelical movement that failed a
generation John Ward welcome John
thank you Andrew good to see you uh it's
great to see you too
um so this book uh taught me a lot
um it did raise a lot of questions so
I'm pumped to have you here with me
um so first can you help people who
might not be as familiar
how would you define uh evangelicals I
mean it's it's a tricky tricky question
um
for a long time
evangelicals were like a hybrid
and I would say that half of the meaning
of the word was cultural political and
half the word was more like theological
and the theological half has a lot to do
with a very strict usually pretty
literal reading of the Bible and then an
instinct to want to proselytize or share
you know for example your testimony but
also you know share your faith and
convert people or get people to to
convert to uh to your faith and then the
other half was cultural political
there's actually like five Hallmarks of
a classic Evangelical theologically
um called the bebington quadrilateral I
think if people want to look into that
and then I think over the last decade
the cultural political angle or or
component of the Evangelical identity
has really kind of overtaken uh the
definition much more so than the
theological the religious component
there's still a lot of people in America
and quite frankly around around the
world
um who you know are Evangelical in that
classic theological sense but certainly
the way that evangelicalism has become a
pretty pretty distinct voting block and
and has kind of locked in with Trump has
has made it more of a political thing I
think one of the things that my book is
trying to explain is that
a lot of evangelicals were locked in
politically with the GOP
um going back a couple decades and
that's been fairly well known but I
think it became just more hard to miss
over the last several years
yeah so you grew up the son of a pastor
yourself
um one of seven children uh you grew up
uh Evangelical as you painstakingly
document and I certainly felt for
younger you
um so one of the jarring elements was
there was a decision where your family
was like obviously he's not going to
public school and that that really took
me back I was like what like
that be like obviously not going to
public school you were homeschooled for
much of uh your childhood uh What
proportion of evangelicals do you think
attend public school I think that I
don't have any data on this but if I
were to guess
I would say that it's more now than it
was when I was a kid
um I think there's been a move towards
more cultural assimilation in some
respects among evangelicals uh cultural
normalization at the same time there's a
greater capacity over the last 10 to 20
years to stay in an information uh sort
of bubble you know as the internet has
provided us more ways of
um you know being in these silos away
from each other not just evangelicals
everybody you know has that temptation
to stay in their Silo but back in the
70s and 80s when I was growing up
um the movie The The Village by M Night
Shyamalan uh kind of describes the
mentality that my parents generation and
some number of evangelicals had about
trying to keep their kids out of too
much contact with people who are not not
just Christians but who were not the
kind of Christians we were
yeah so you were homeschooled
um and my wife and I joke about
homeschooling our two kids and just
concluded would be way too much work
you're repaired yourself so you probably
can relate to aspects of that well we
all had homeschooling and during covet
right I mean that was all yeah yeah yeah
we all we all got an education ourselves
so so you learned a lot of pressure I
suppose as a pastor's kid you had one
story where your dad was like Hey like
be more active in service and you're
like oh Dad you're just trying to make
yourself look good he was like yeah
that's right
and I was like well that actually is
pretty uh like pretty uh ballsy on your
part as a kid and then pretty High
character of him
um and I think uh some of the most
personal stuff and I commend you for it
because I think it is kind of vital to
understanding so you talk about uh how
the the culture doesn't necessarily lend
itself to a lot of intellectual
exploration
um or uh relationship exploration where
you were
um kind of uh confessing about a number
of times a week you you masturbated to a
group of other people on a Starbucks and
you were like why the hell are we doing
this at a Starbucks uh so
um and I thought that both of these uh
strains were were extraordinarily
powerful in terms of explaining how the
the culture is formed one of the um
interesting moments about that Starbucks
cringe moment you know scene is that I
was asking myself why are we doing this
in a Starbucks
as I wrote that part I tried to think
back to whether I questioned why we were
doing it at all
and it's an interesting like
juxtaposition there to me that I was
questioning some component of it but I'm
not sure that I really questioned the
overall thrust of what we were doing
um and so they're you're like this could
be this could be better situated
yeah I mean I I was highly uncomfortable
but at the same time I describe how
you know I would be one of the first
people to kind of jump into
participation because I was so committed
to it at the time
um one of the ways that I am probably
most
unevangelical at this point
um goes to the issue you just raised
about
intellectual exploration
um intellectual openness
um I still you know consider myself a
Christian and consider my faith to be
very important to me and and Incredibly
powerful
but I think a big difference between the
way I was raised and the way I am now is
that I just hold
pretty much most of my beliefs with a
much more open hand
because
I don't live in a very small closed
system or culture where a high degree of
my belonging depends on how fervently I
express adherence to these views and
once you get I think out of that kind of
a social setting you have more
Independence to kind of work through
intellectually you know the fact that we
just can't know for sure
the the answers to any of this which is
why we call it faith and it's why we
can't be certain about matters of Faith
at least in you know in my view I don't
think it's very healthy to do it that
way
um and then I also write about the fact
that over the last several years people
who are certain about things that we
can't know for sure became relativists
about things that we did know such as
you know Public Health measures to try
to mitigate the
um the spread of covid or who won the
2020 election it wasn't necessarily that
I was encountering people all the time
who are saying you know evangelicals who
are saying I know that you know Trump
won it was actually something even more
puzzling and uh infuriating at times
which was well they'd kind of Trot out a
few
um conspiracy theories or things that
they heard on the Internet or read on
the internet
I would present them with you know
evidence to the contrary and then they
would kind of throw up their hands and
say well we can't really know for sure
and um and it just was like this very
bizarre uh upside down well I think one
of the most important elements of your
book uh is helping people understand how
the Evangelical Community regards uh The
Establishment media institutions where
you're growing up
um uh in a culture that feels like it's
in a parallel track uh and in opposition
and there's also a sense that these
institutions and the media look down
their nose at you I mean you have a
story
um about your being on MSNBC and quoting
scripture and I'm just like what the
heck
and you're you're like I don't think
that that took now you're you're this
fascinating figure where you're now
straddling uh the the national
journalism World which I'm going to
suggest is very very secularized
um and and this Evangelical upbringing
um and I think one of the most important
things for people to understand is look
like a lot of these people are raised in
a in in an environment where uh they
feel like they are in opposition to
these uh institutions and these media
messages and so this relationship with
information that you're describing where
you present to evangelicals hey here's
some evidence on let's say covet or or
whatnot
um I think one of the most powerful
forces that Trump has tapped into is
this
anti-institutional sentiment yeah 100
um I use the analogy that for a long
time the relationship between people in
the world I grew up in
evangelicals
their relationship with
you know the news media in general and
and institutions
uh
non-religious institutions mostly
their relationship to that world was uh
was very strained
um if I think I used the metaphor of a
tree where the the branch or the
connective tissue between evangelicals
and and secular Media or secular
institutions was hanging by a thread
and Trump came along and really snapped
it in half and then kind of brought a
lot of people with him into an
alternative epistemic universe and I I
think that issue of epistemology how do
we know what we know
is at the root of so many of the issues
driving our cultural political
dysfunction today yeah especially now
yeah it's why I think Jonathan roush's
book
um the constitution of knowledge
um is so important and it's a start
Jonathan's book is a starting point
because it's it's dense it's uh it needs
a lot more like bringing out of the
lessons he talks about
um into real world applications
but if we can't kind of establish a
baseline of how we produce knowledge
that everyone can kind of share as a
starting point for disagreement and
debate
and also a system for resolving those
disagreements without violence then
um we're going to continue to see I
think a lot of the dysfunction that
we're talking about or that we're seeing
and I think you know you pointed to it
there is this parallel universe that I
grew up in which in some ways was
motivated by a sense that we know better
than people who are not like us who
don't don't believe like like us but it
also creates
um that sense of opposition that sense
of we're going to be persecuted
um they're out to get us uh and and so
all of that is what was going on for a
very long time before Trump ever came
along which was a big part of the mix
and I'm really glad that you are
um are perceiving the ways I think that
I the book lays out how the ground was
seated for a long time
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
in a tough economy you're looking for
ways to save money and you know a sneaky
way you can do it expressvpn now you're
asking yourself how is that possible
doesn't expressvpn cost money it does
cost less than seven dollars a month but
it can help you unlock content that will
save you money for days and days what do
I mean for example let's say I'm a Duran
Duran fan which I am I want to watch the
concert movie of Duran Duran but it is
not available on Netflix in the US
however with expressvpn I can just beam
myself into the UK click on Netflix and
voila Duran Duran and a bunch of other
content I could not have gotten any
other way it's a no-brainer if you want
to preserve your own data from the big
tech companies and get more content and
save money while you're at it go to
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my link so you can get three extra
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Yang expressvpn.com to learn more
foreign
so one of the things I was thinking when
I was reading the first part of your
book which was about your upbringing and
all these experiences I was like how the
heck does this dude become a national
reporter
so so you you are
um
so you in turn at a paper in in DC the
Washington Times they ask you if you
want to cover local news or Sports you
were a sports nut how close did you come
to just saying Sports
you know close but I also felt like um
if I covered Sports then I would lose my
love of sports because it would just
become smart a job so uh and I also I
also my other calculation at that time
was it would be much easier to go from
news to sports if I didn't like news
than it would be to go from Sports to
news because I just felt like the the
skills or the whatever was not as
transferable from Sports to news as it
was the other way around which I I think
was generally correct nice job young you
so you get so uh you get promoted you
become a reporter wind up climbing the
ranks uh you work for the Huffington
Post for a particular period you worked
for the Daily Caller
um I think that I had that out of order
it might have been Daily Caller than
Huffington Post
[Laughter]
Tucker and then Ariana right yeah so I
mean talk about the polls I mean like
most people think like you know that
there's not much in common
um there um this there's a quote from
you that I love so much
um which I think talks about your desire
to learn and intellectually explore
first and foremost truth Seekers don't
search for battles outside themselves to
win instead they examine their own point
of view searching for holes weaknesses
errors uh and you referred earlier to
the fact that those in your community uh
feel like you know better you know
things other people don't and then there
was a desire to to proselytize uh to
expand the faith
um and that
that approach uh seems to have
encountered to the quote um that that I
just read in the sense that
um hey I'm not really examining
um my own point of view uh like I'm
spreading a point of view I'm certain
about to others yeah and I also write
about how I still have that instinct
kind of deep in my bones and I've got to
check myself to not take that same
Instinct With A New Perspective and
continue to act as if I know better than
other people or you know other people
need to think like I do because that
that kind of uh Instinct can can be hard
to get rid of if it's the way you've
been you've been raised I think I'm
doing better and it's interesting when
you I don't think before I wrote this
book I would have traced
that approach to knowledge and Truth
back to its source the way that you do
when you kind of explore your own story
and write about it and think about it
which I encourage everybody to do it in
some form I think it's a really healthy
process to do
every 10 20 years even
um what's that another book in the next
10 to 20 years I'm kidding I know I
totally agree with you John where you
actually learn a lot by putting a pen to
paper and your thoughts down especially
if you wind up including your own
experiences because you don't think
about your own childhood every day
and I wouldn't have it wasn't until I
did this process that I was able to come
to a pretty strong conclusion that my
approach to truth owes a lot of its
roots back to my dad and the way that he
taught us about faith even if he and I
he and I disagree about a lot of things
religiously and politically today and
he's a pretty big character in the book
but yeah but he he taught me a certain
way and he taught me from certain books
of the Bible which I think shaped a lot
of my approach to this so you wind up
the chief National correspondent for
Yahoo uh you've covered uh several
presidents at this point you've written
in Air Force One uh you've tracked
various presidential campaigns
um What proportion of Big Shot
journalists like yourself uh are of an
Evangelical background
yeah I mean in DC there are pockets of
people who kind of connect with one
another and then you realize you have
similar backgrounds or similar faiths I
think the thing that's notable to me in
thinking about this question not just
when you asked it but
a bunch of people have kind of brought
this up
is that I think we just don't do a very
good job of creating space for people to
talk about this because I think there's
more people than we realize who have
maybe not the same Faith background but
take Faith very seriously
and and there's just not a lot of
conversation about it because it is I
think I think it has come to be seen as
something that is more of a private
matter than is something that
um
that is like something to be talked
about in public company and it was
healthy for me to go through the process
of writing this because it has given me
the ability and the language to talk
about things and just the practice to
talk about these matters
in ways that are I think maybe make
people they're more translatable more
accessible to people
um but in terms of like a percentage of
people who are in The Press who have my
background it's probably not a lot
um that was one of the things I thought
to myself I was like I feel like John
might be something of a unicorn
um
I I think one you know one of the
realities here is that
I think to get anywhere in life it
doesn't it probably doesn't help to be
in a position where your family and your
immediate sort of social network
is not just not focused on
uh financial and educational achievement
but is kind of actively pushing away
from that
um and so I did start from behind in a
lot of ways and I think that's one of
the reasons why people from these types
of backgrounds have a hard time making
it there's also this massive skepticism
of these institutions that you know
baked into a lot of your
um family members uh and
um I loved your conversations because we
all uh like heard about some of us
experienced
um the internists and family uh Strife
over Trump
um yeah and you even document the
conversations you had with your family
there's one story you had that was so
painful to me which was uh but honest
there's a lot of your book where you're
like whoa like you know
um kudos for sharing that so you go back
and visit your family and they've got uh
Trump Pence signs up and you're just
like I can't
like like I don't wanna
like uh have these signs up while I'm
I'm having dinner and so you take the
sides and uh like put one in the bushes
put another one in like you know maybe a
part of the garage that it wasn't in and
then you have dinner that you leave and
then your family's like hey what
happened to the sides and you're like oh
yeah I threw it in the bushes
and they're they're livid they're like
you know freaking Furious that you um
for doing that uh you know you detail
various exchanges you had where you have
like long messages where you're like
trying to persuade your family members
of this and I I thought that their
responses to you were so telling because
their responses spoke for not just them
but you know uh millions of other
Americans who are responding the same
way yeah I thought it was important to
include the ways that I screwed up and
the ways that I went too far and got too
angry or too hot over the last few years
I mean when I went to my parents house
that that night when they had the signs
in the yard I had been spending months
sort of reporting very closely on how
people could vote during the pandemic
and I had been doing months of work on
exploring what was true and what was
false about you know the issue of voter
fraud and voter suppression all these
things around voting so and we were
right before I got to my parents house
like the week or two before that it was
becoming clearer how Republicans in
state legislatures were going to delay
the counting of the votes to give space
for Trump to claim that the election was
stolen this was two months before the
election and so it was very clear to me
that Trump was was waging a very open
kind of uh assault on reality and on
Democracy at that point
um and and uh and I regret you know
doing what I did but I thought it was
important
um to be in there
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah and so there's some quotes from uh
um from you and from your family that
you know I kind of wanted to share
um because I thought they were so
um so telling some of my family also
exhibited a desire to blow up everything
in our government and politics out of
some nebulous mix of fear and rage and
this is something a lot of Americans
know is going on but because you're
close to it
um you you know speak about it
personally and these are your your
relatives
um the fear came from a sense that the
left wanted to police their beliefs
their language even their thoughts uh
there were also outraged by the sense
that discussing systemic racism was a
way to label all white people as racist
this combination of factors produced a
nihilism that shocked me one sibling
told me he wanted to burn it all down
and see what emerged from the ruins
another relative told me that if Trump
turned out to be an authoritarian
Americans could turn him out of office
with a coup I looked at his face closely
to see if he was joking and he was
serious so these were sentiments that
that uh you know you had Direct
conversations with family members about
and that there are a lot of Americans
who who feel the same way yeah and this
was the 2016 time period and um
there was just a lot of things being
surfaced that
I think myself and many other people
just thought were beyond the realm of
the thinkable but it's that old idea of
the Overton window you know the the art
of the realm of what's possible it just
began it just began to just like shift
in a major way and so yeah I was having
these conversations
uh and just kind of stunned at what I
was hearing it again Taps into
that oppositional mindset that goes a
long ways back which you know I write in
the book how right I cite a book on
evangelicalism written by a historian
named Francis Fitzgerald she's one of
many historians who have documented how
this anti-institutionalism goes back to
you know hundreds of years ago because
evangelicalism grew out of a class-based
uh you know dispute uh in the American
uh Frontier over over religion
but I think it's a whole other thing
which is what I'm kind of getting from
your response to the book to see
somebody living today who's in a
mainstream media job who grew up in this
world
um who's who's telling stories uh from
the front lines of That World
um and that oppositional mindset just
thinks like you know they're out to get
us and we're already kind of keeping to
ourselves so we don't have a lot of
one-on-one or real world contact with
them the people who are out to get us so
our our fears can kind of just continue
to escalate and keep going and there are
people out there making money off of uh
exacerbating those fears and playing in
those fears and so
I I don't dismiss and I've said this
elsewhere I don't dismiss the fact that
like if you're a very conservative
religious person and you have very
conservative views on social issues uh a
lot especially around sexuality I don't
dispute that there are people uh you
know on the other side who
um are are saying things or doing things
that that raise concerns about religious
liberty or your right to have that
opinion or your right to say that
opinion I do think those fears are
sometimes exaggerated but I also
acknowledge they exist and and and there
are reasons for them my perspective as a
as a person of faith is that faith uh
gives us a lot of things including
courage to you know advocate for our
point of view
um but then not try to run roughshod
over uh the rights or whatever of other
people Yeah in our attempt to get what
we want well I think that's the key to
this where I had a conversation with
um someone of Faith the the other day
um and he said uh look I believe certain
things
um you know you may believe something
else
um the problem I have is that I'm being
painted as immoral or a bad person for
holding the beliefs that I believe right
uh and and I I think that's the
fundamental problem where we're a very
diverse uh country on on multiple levels
uh and we shouldn't imagine that other
people are going to believe the same
thing uh we believe
um but we should still respect them and
accept them
um and you know they may be living a
different life than than we are but we
may even want to engage in the
conversation with them and say hey like
why do you feel this way like I feel
this way and maybe I can persuade you to
a certain point of view that the problem
arises when the message is like you're a
bad person you're lesser you're maybe
even less than human because you uh
believe a certain thing uh or live a
certain way yeah and and there's also
often this assumption that and this
actually can go different directions but
there's an assumption that I've come to
the right conclusion and everybody
around me thinks the same thing and so
people who think differently like just
need to get with the program and if they
don't then
um you know there's something wrong with
them uh I think one of the things that
my book is trying to convey
is that it takes a long time for anyone
to uh evolve and change and for their
perspective to grow
um and you know I do think my
perspective has evolved in a positive
direction
people from where I come from probably
disagree
um the point is that all of this stuff
takes a long time and so I think
patience with one another is really
important even if we vehemently disagree
now there are you know views that
um you know we we have a lot of freedom
in this country to to say and believe
things that are offensive to one another
and you know the law on the First
Amendment
um does limit our speech uh on certain
things but it's only at a very like high
Tipping Point of incitement to violence
uh and a couple other situations and so
I think extending that into our personal
um uh interactions uh is healthy so much
of this problem with social media you
know I mean you and I both grew up in
the 70s and there were people probably
you know a few doors down who had like
had beliefs that I you know I might have
found offensive but they just talk about
uh it with you know their their friends
in the garage and you know like like we
don't have to have an argument about
about it right I I think that that's
where so much of it is uh
Amplified
nowadays if you imagine a world where
like social media you know went away
then all of a sudden it's you know it's
like we're we're in a very different
environment
um and you and I have like bridged that
world now you have kids of your own who
are probably a little bit too young for
social media
um my not happily I think are are as
well
um but I do live in
um some degree of trepidation and
anxiety about the world they're
inheriting uh
um as a result of the fact that I think
there are real pressures to say certain
things and believe certain things and if
you don't then you'll be cast out of the
group and unfortunately now
um we're so polarized that there are uh
like these you know two dominant
narratives or groups that that you fear
being cast out of yeah I mean I have a
lot of thoughts and first of all our
oldest is 15 so um oh yeah then they're
at the cusp man so I didn't realize your
kids were at that it gives a little
older than mine we've we've held the
line as much as possible and really
limited their use of of social media
yeah and and I'm really glad that we
have going back to what we were just
talking about though if people if we
don't give other people patience
um I think people will just stop trying
to uh understand the other point of view
or evolve or grow if it becomes zero-sum
and we don't give each other room and
space to kind of
think things or say things that we
disagree with everybody just kind of
retreats to their Corners there's it
actually reduces the amount of progress
I think
um that we make oh yeah for sure
um you know there has to be this sense
of shared Humanity
uh and
uh Fellowship uh you know you have to be
able to come to the table and you've
you've done this because you've had uh
the experiences you've had
um you sit down on the table someone who
might be from another way of life and
you expect one thing and then after like
10 minutes you're like oh this person's
actually like you know like fine
like how many times have you had that
that experience I've had it thousands of
times now I can't imagine how many times
you've had a running for office I mean I
mean you've had I've had lots of
conversations uh in my professional
capacity
um with people who are different who I
get to ask questions from and just
listen to them which is really quite a
gift to to not have any pressure any ego
pressure any social pressure to do
anything other than just sit and listen
and ask questions it's it's like
life-changing and I can't imagine how
many times running for office you've had
exponentially probably more
conversations and I think both of us you
know are lucky in that respect because a
lot of people they have to make more of
an effort to be in similar situations
where they can seek out those kinds of
conversations I don't think it's
relative I don't think it's really the
norm for people to have an easy access
to that
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
what the heck is Helix sleep it is the
mattress of the future company I have
always been someone who valued my sleep
figured you know you're gonna do it for
seven maybe even eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and energized what is
that worth Helix sleep can help make
that happen just take their sleep quiz
and figure out what personalized
mattress should be shipped straight to
your door and you have a hundred days to
return it I don't recommend returning it
after 99 days but hey who am I to say
don't take my word for it it's the
number one rated mattress from GQ and
wired can you imagine being the mattress
tester it's a job someone has it Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
right now go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep start
Starts Now
[Music]
so you had a quote early in the book
um that I was like well that's the most
interesting uh term I've seen in quite
some time it was a border stalker
there was the sense that you have these
tribes who are uh you know defined in a
certain way and and
you talk about a lot of the the youthful
experiences you had was like Hey we're
all gonna do this we're all gonna
um uh sing this or feel a certain way
and then you present this idea from a
thinker
um then there are these people that are
border stalkers
um uh and uh how would like uh like what
what is what does it mean to be a border
stalker comes from a book called uh
culture Care by Mako fujimura who's a
painter and an author and um I just love
that term because it contravenes the
idea of culture War yeah and uh Mako
talks about how you know culture is not
a territory to be one it's a it's a
garden to be cared for wow we we should
put that out far and wide man say that
again like uh culture is not a territory
to be one uh it's uh was it a resource
to be tended yeah I mean something along
those lines I actually just kind of
threw in the garden to be cared for but
it's it's something I don't remember the
exact language he uses but it's
something to that effect and he
definitely says it's not a territory to
be won and you know a border stalker he
got it from Beowulf uh and and it's a
term in Old English I think that he he
said uh is mirxtapa which is an even
weirder word
um and kind of uh interesting I
resonated with that because growing up I
didn't feel completely at home in church
even though I tried to uh I tried to
belong
um I think again going back maybe to my
dad and some mix of DNA like I just
couldn't stop asking
um sort of questions about you know why
do we do this why do we think that but I
tried to belong and so I was sort of
and they were elevating you to
leadership positions man they had you on
stage speaking and doing age
yeah
um that was in like my college Years
again though I kind of couldn't say I
couldn't be enough of a yes man even
though I I think I tried and yet I'm not
I'm not really at home in secular or
mainstream media as well
um and I never I always kind of set out
to to kind of keep myself at arm's
length from both like the TV
establishment and like the cocktail
party establishment
um just out of like almost instinct and
so a border stalker is somebody who
actually
I think
it's somewhat constitutional I think
it's not a role for everybody but I
think closed groups and societies
need to recognize their need for these
types of people who move between groups
and tribes and both ask uncomfortable
questions inside those groups but also
try to bring understanding between
different groups yeah I
I think this idea of being a border
stalker is incredibly important and and
I joked once when someone asked like hey
why should you be president and I
thought to myself well the real answer
is that I just don't socialize very
easily
if you put me in a group and the group's
like hey we should do this I'm just like
should we
um so uh you know I I might have said
that to like my staff at one point they
didn't understand it I guess I could
have said I'm a border stalker and they
also wouldn't have understood that
um but I I think this idea that uh
there's this Collective or a tribe and
then you're not like you know in the at
the front of it or in the middle of it I
mean you said like hey look I tried you
know and yeah you know obviously a
person of faith and
um and they were trying to elevate you
in certain ways and you're the the group
leader
um but you naturally wound up
um trying to test the the borders of
um of what you believe uh you know you
wanted to absorb new uh pieces of
information and your book closes on what
I think is the most powerful important
message I've seen in quite some time
um which is Christians can and should
become agents of nuance rather than of
reductionism and I was like wow is that
powerful this means embracing complexity
and rejecting easy explanations there's
a journalist named Amanda Ripley who
wrote a book called high conflict
um I hope I'm getting that right I think
that's correct
and I I think the book came out of an
essay she wrote called complicating the
narrative
um we live in a time where
there is so much information
there's so much entertainment
there's so much stress and busyness and
so we're all dealing with a need to
simplify
and so that is the the pressure that
adds on top of the natural human
instinct to reduce things to you know
understandable terms understandable
Concepts
so I understand the instinct to reduce
and simplify
but when it comes to
issues of disagreement especially
we have to resist that instinct because
once we oversimplify and reduce things
then those who disagree with us are
caricatured and demonized into just bad
people yep and it's never that simple
almost ever I mean I I want to say never
but there probably are some situations
where you know the person we disagree
with or the or the bad person really is
just mostly bad but most the time like
people are coming from their point of
view and they think they have good
motives and good reasons for what
they're doing and
um I I think a Christian's duty is to
bring healing to the world and to be the
hands and feet of Christ and to bring
love uh to our to our neighbor to love
our neighbor as Christ told us and I
think do a big part of that is
complicating The Narrative resisting
those easy answers because I think
that's a big part of loving our neighbor
yeah again it's a beautiful message I
mean you summarize it
in this way it said to love God to love
those around you and to lift up the
downtrodden it doesn't seem like it
should have to be too much more
complicated than that and I was like
well that that seems like a very pure
message you do at one point reference
that there there are other religious
communities and one of the things this
uh that that this made me think of was
my visit to the King Center in Atlanta
or where obviously you know when I went
to the Ebenezer Baptist Church and the
message there was uh like you know
anti-racism anti-poverty anti-war and uh
like you know these messages strike me
as as very Universal uh and deeply
Christian yeah I I don't know how to
talk to people from I probably shouldn't
even say this but like I don't know how
to talk to people from sort of
conservative religious circles about the
whole issue of how you view other faiths
because for me it's not I don't feel
conflicted about it but I know if you
have very conservative
religious views
especially if you believe in like
hell
you know there are millions of people
probably hundreds of millions of people
around the world who believe that if you
believe the wrong thing
uh you're you're punished forever I
don't know what the numbers are there's
a lot of people who believe that yes and
um
and that that that's a whole nother big
ingredient
in everything we're talking about
because it it it also reduces some
things to a very zero-sum issue you know
like if if I don't convince you to think
like me
you're gonna suffer for all of eternity
I mean you can understand if you really
believe that that it pushes you to make
some pretty radical extreme decisions
and how you interact with people
um how you engage in public life and in
politics
um so I'm not even sure why I went off
on that other than to say I agree with
you that those principles uh from the
King Center are really compelling and
I've come to a place where I believe in
Christianity and I hold it dearly and it
motivates me and it empowers my life but
I'm much more interested in how I'm
living my life and how others are living
their lives for those simple Baseline
values of loving God and loving creation
and loving our neighbor and helping
those who need it rather than being
absolutely pure on how I think about uh
this religious Doctrine or that one
yeah I mean you you could lead with love
thy neighbor and it would solve a lot
and you know maybe your your neighbor
might even be of the other party uh you
know I mean one of the the things about
polarization nowadays is that politics
have replaced religion in terms of
um what you're concerned uh about your
child uh dating or marrying it's like
I'd be much more accepting of them have
a very different Faith as long as that
they're of the same uh political
persuasion and that is new it it used to
be very much the other way around you
know I think I think a big part of the
reason for that
is because religion
became increasingly irrelevant to
everyday life if there's no real
connection between what you're hearing
in church or you know
reading in the Bible or your other
sacred text let's just say the Bible for
now because I don't want to talk about
religious Traditions I'm not qualified
to comment on sure but if there's not a
lot of relevance between those things
and and the issues of everyday life that
are really pressing and important then
you are going to look somewhere else for
um a framework for how to engage that
and I that's one of the I think the Big
Ideas in my book is that the Evangelical
Church has
pretty objectively failed to train
people in how not just to be a good
person in in their private lives and
their families and in their churches and
in their workplaces but how to be a good
Christian uh for the common good and for
your neighbor
in all of life including politics I
would call that public character and I
don't think that the Evangelical Church
largely the white conservative event
Evangelical Church has really put a
whole lot of work into that whereas I
think uh other streams of Christianity
have I think Catholics have done a lot
of work on this I think the black church
has done a lot of work on this yeah you
you talk about how evangelicals uh
rejected Clinton because of his uh you
know sexual misconduct and then when
Trump came along it's like well you know
like like Let's ignore it and then and
and there there was like an aspect of
that where you're like yeah you know
that doesn't seem seem terribly
um consistent it was inconsistent but to
me I think
that was never the most compelling
criticism to me the the lack of training
and discernment in the Evangelical
Church meant that people weren't even
able to think outside of the regular
Democrat Republican uh Paradigm uh
because if they were able to do that
they could have seen the way that Trump
kind of stood outside of either party
and was really running against democracy
uh and he was running against a free
press he he he criticized Democrats and
Hillary Clinton but
um the criticisms that I waged and
others waged of trump and still do are
not partisan or ideological well you
know he was running against a set of
Institutions and because many
evangelicals felt uh like in opposition
to those institutions he became uh their
guy yeah uh and and that relationship I
mean it's going to be tested again now
it seems very hard for any of the other
candidates to break in their uh you know
especially because Trump does have some
concrete victories uh that he can point
to your your closing message
um I think is awesome and it's something
that I hope forward party actually uh
can be a part of politically a credible
Christian presence would be prophetic it
would not be captive to any one
political party imagine that it would be
free to praise both Democrats and
Republicans and free to critique them
both as well
to the degree it would be a voting block
it would represent a group of Voters who
could not be won over with appeals to
tribal Identity or by fear-based appeals
that demonize minority groups to the
other side this voting Bloc would
support politicians who demonstrate a
Devotion to solid principles these
voters would reward politicians who put
the good of the whole country or state
or County or town ahead of their own
careers who risk losing their political
post in order to preserve the stability
of the political system for future
Generations I mean what what a beautiful
Vision that is it's a politics of Love
rather than of fear
or opposition or hate it's a it's a
politics of love of country and
um and love of what this country has
stood for which is imperfectly
uh creating and maintaining a system in
which we can continue to strive towards
um
you know freedom of speech freedom of
Association freedom of conscience
equality uh even though obviously we
have not done that anywhere close to
perfectly
um you know I talk in the book about my
own uh realization of of the depths of
you know race racism and structural
inequality in the book and and a lot of
times that's called now just like wokism
like any acknowledgment of that is just
wokism and it's a Cancer and all that
and um
and I love this country more than ever
as a result of studying its history and
I and I think this country has done
immense good it's also done a lot of bad
but I love it and I think that there are
not a lot of other great options in
human history uh for what we've
accomplished in this country as much as
it has been uh highly imperfect and
often you know quite dark and so the the
politics you're describing there
yeah the one that we're we're both kind
of I think in search of is one that is
motivated by a love of that
um rather than uh you know what we hate
I mean what's the term
um negative polarization that's the term
I think the sign the political
scientists use that is what is
motivating uh increasingly large numbers
of political decisions is uh who do I
hate more uh we gotta we gotta break out
of that or who do I hate less really
very very often correct um you know I'm
the son of immigrants I love this
country dearly as well
um despite all of its imperfections uh
and and
flaws what we could really use as a
political movement that puts that love
of your neighbor and love of country
above uh defeating the other side maybe
because maybe there isn't another side
you know what I mean like maybe that's
not the way you see the world
that it's like me against you and said
it's like wait like you know you're
probably more like me than I I realized
yeah that's that scarcity mindset that
thinks that everything is a zero-sum
game
um but yeah I uh I couldn't agree more
with you on that well John
congratulations uh on a phenomenal
achievement and contribution uh
testimony inside the Evangelical
movement that failed a generation so
people want to keep up with you uh and
your reporting how can they best do so I
have a website that has information on
the book
um with also links to uh where I write
on sub stack uh and the website is
johnwardrights.org j-o-n-w-a-r-d
writes
w-r-i-t-e-s dot org um and uh on my
Twitter
j-o-n-w-a-r-d11 you can also find a link
to my stuff that I'm writing for Yahoo
news uh those would be the the top
places to go so grateful uh that you've
put your story out there in such a
powerful and compelling way and I hope
that uh uh Americans read and take heed
appreciate the work you do a great deal
thank you Andrew it's good to see you
again I think the last time I saw you
was following following you around
Manhattan
um and uh I enjoyed that very much I've
enjoyed watching uh your you know
political entrepreneurship I think it's
been like fascinating and inspiring so
thank you for having me on oh thanks man
good times uh come back anytime
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh